welcome back to las vegas now the 20th
annual las vegas juneteenth festival is
tomorrow this
is an extremely important day to
celebrate and educate so let's welcome
festival coordinator jay haywood
for more information on how to get
involved hey jay
hello how are you i'm good how you doing
good to see you
i'm doing well thank you so much just
trying to stay cool oh
we all are we all are but let's start
with educating the community on the
juneteen festival for those who don't
know
what is juneteenth and why are we
celebrating it
well we celebrate juneteenth because
back in 1863
when abraham lincoln signed the
emancipation proclamation that we all
know so well
unfortunately all slaves weren't freed
when that was signed
slaves people still continue to be in
slavery in the deep south and
and toward texas up until mid 2000 or
mid 1865. so if you can imagine being a
slave
two and a half years after the
proclamation was signed these people
didn't get the word because
it just wasn't you know it hadn't been
gotten down to them so general granger
goes down he delivers the word
jubilation breaks out on june 19 1865
when everyone realizes that we are free
the emancipation has been signed and
that every african slave in this country
is now free and we're free from that
bondage of slavery
wow so this is celebrating that's why we
celebrate a total amount of freedom for
the for the community so let's move on
to celebration it's the perfect segue so
where
what time and what can we expect at the
dune team festival tomorrow
oh well the las vegas june team festival
has been a staple here this is our 20th
year
tomorrow we're going to be at 951 west
lake mead boulevard at doolittle
community center
the festival was originally slated to be
outdoors we like it to be an outdoor
open air event
unfortunately because of the excessive
temperatures in conjunction with the
city we decided to move it inside
to make sure the public safety was uh
protected so now we're going to be
inside doolittle community center
from 6 p.m to 9 p.m for this festival
that's awesome
definitely need to be inside during this
this heat and who's behind the festival
the the festival is uh uh was founded by
miss diane pollard
it's a fundraiser our annual fundraiser
not only to bring awareness to june
teens but also to raise money for
rainbow dreams educational foundation
and we have our event signature
sponsored each year which is zappos so
zappos black awareness and rainbow
dreams academy and rainbow dreams
educational foundation
along with councilman cedric creer from
ward 5 are bringing this event to las
vegas this year for our 20th annual
perfect and jay last year but not least
you know what do you want people to walk
away with
after they after they visit the festival
what do you want people to learn
we want people to learn what juneteenth
is all about because a lot of people
still don't know why we celebrate
juneteenth right
but we also want people to understand
that although we've come so far
we still have a long way to go as
african-americans as people in this
country not only african-americans
but we want them to learn that it's okay
to celebrate it's okay to come together
woulsa a little bit celebrate how far
we've come but to reflect on where we've
been so we know
that we still have a long way to go so
it's going to be entertainment
we're going to have dancing food live
acts we're going to have vaccination
stations from
uh first med liberty dental's going to
be doing dental screenings
we're going to be doing a little bit of
everything but it's going to be a
celebration for this holiday
it's monumental holiday jay thank you so
much we're excited for all the culture
and community we appreciate it and have
fun
tomorrow thank you so much we appreciate